hi folks uh we're starting in few
minutes
foreign
folks
uh meanwhile awesome
I'm your host uh for today's evening
awesome awesome thank you so much guys
so we'll be starting the career master
class uh and we'll be talking about how
you can kick start your career in 2023
uh and digital marketing career like a
pro and we'll be talking about the
ultimate players on map right so I would
love to know where you folks are from
meanwhile folks are joining in so I'll
just introduce myself here
uh my name is Russia and I'm your host
and I am from Bangalore India I am just
typing it over over chart because I
would love to chat with you guys
before we start
so I am from Bangalore India and uh
would love to know where you folks are
from you can just type it over chat here
welcome everyone uh folks who are just
joining now just to let you know we're
starting in few minutes
meanwhile uh you guys can just uh talk
over chat and let us know where you're
from so we'll get to know each other
better
okay I can see someone has asked
mashavan has asked can we get recording
of of this particular webinar yes you
will get it uh post webinar uh on a mail
and you can view it in case you know you
want to go through it again I can see
folks have started introducing
themselves on chat here I can see folks
who have joined from Mumbai I can see
sudarshan has joined from Mumbai I can
see modise has joined from Botswana
I can see mushroom has joined from Tamil
Nadu kalyani where have you joined us
from
I can see Renee from South Africa
awesome kalyani good to have you here
hi uh before we start the session uh
let's just wait for some more time and
Infamous will start the session
So today we're going to talk about
career master class on digital marketing
program by Purdue University meanwhile I
can see the introductions are still
going on on chat I can see bhumika from
Rajasthan
please do introduce yourself on chat
here
uh so uh speaker is joining in just few
minutes uh there is a little delay uh so
meanwhile Audrey can do it so I can see
that people have started talking on chat
here and I can see more introductions
coming in so just to let you know folks
who have just joined a little league uh
that we'll be talking about the career
masterclass and uh in digital marketing
by bird University and today we are
going to talk about the career roadmap
as well so if you have any questions
what you can do is you can put your
questions in the Q a section uh of here
or either you have joined from your
laptop or mobile
and also
yeah if we are putting questions on the
chart here so sorry we might miss it
because we get a lot of messages on chat
so meanwhile what we can do is if you
have questions about digital marketing
if you're confused about it if you want
to know more about the Purdue University
course if you want to know uh if you are
an experienced person if you are a
fresher like what kind of questions you
know you might have and we'll be taking
those questions uh during the webinar so
what you can do is you can go and put
your questions in the Q a let's utilize
this time and also new folks who are
joining in we are just starting in few
minutes
foreign
my name is Russia and I'm your host
today
before we start uh I would love to know
uh as I can see folks have joined from
different different uh parts of the
world
where are you folks from oh
I can see bernardite uh speaker has
already joined us so uh hi Benedict uh
let us start the session
hi excellent
uh
yes you are audible can you hear me
hello
can you hear me okay just just
hi uh
yes I can hear you just fine okay
awesome awesome
how are you doing I'm doing well awesome
I was saying let's start the career
master class uh so uh we can see a lot
of folks have joined from different
different parts of the world and uh
while you were uh not here like you know
while you're joining they actually were
introducing themselves and telling us
where they are from so uh that's really
amazing but Dr now where are you from
um I'm originally from Texas but I am
here uh about 20 minutes outside of the
Atlanta area
okay awesome awesome uh welcome and uh
so we today we are going to talk about
how folks can
uh start their career additional
like a pro and also we'll be talking
about the ultimate career roadmap you
know click and shine in just marketing
uh with Purdue University
very well
uh we have few ground rules uh so folks
if you have any questions you can put it
in the Q a box if you're joined from
your laptop uh from your mobile you will
see a q a box just beside your chat and
you can just post your questions there
uh in case you're putting questions on
in the chat I'm so sorry we actually get
a lot of messages on chat and uh we
really might miss out on the question
you have asked so we'll be taking the
questions uh throughout the session uh
so please have some patience for that
and also I saw like folks were asking if
they'll be getting a recording of this
session uh yes you will receive a
recording link of the session post
webinar uh over your mail and you can
view that recording in case you want to
go through it once again and also you
can also expect a follow-up email with
the recording link and also there's a
bonus offer you know in the in as well
so
let's move on uh so while I I saw that
you guys were giving your introductions
where you're from but I would love to
know how many years of experience do you
folks have so let's get to know each
other better uh so if you can see a poll
on your screen uh if you're currently
studying you can choose that option you
can if you are a fresher you have only
zero to three years of experience you
can choose that option if you're a
mid-level professional you can choose a
third option of three to five years and
if you have more than five years of
experience you can choose the fourth one
and the submit it that it's that easy I
can see folks have already started
voting uh for other few folks who are
left I would really suggest to just go
and vote for the correct option it's a
very easy peasy thing like how much
experience do you have you can see those
four questions on your screen right now
okay I'm gonna give like 10 seconds more
uh to the folks here
and I'm going to end that quote
okay I can see uh half of the folks uh
are actually uh professors or you know
have three to three years of experience
and I can see folks who have uh between
like six to ten years of experience and
I can see uh most of them are working
professionals uh so great thank you so
much
before we move on uh to the career
Master Class
I would like you to introduce you to
bernary Chambers who has joined us here
to take us through the Purdue University
program of regional marketing uh could
you guys give us a good introduction
about yourself and so the audience can
get to know you better
yeah absolutely so uh welcome guys
thanks so much again for joining
um just a little bit blurb I'm not going
to spend a whole lot of time because I'm
pretty sure you want to get into the
meat and potatoes of the training but
um I started with simply learn back in
2017 as one of their uh junior level
trainers work my way up to one of their
senior level trainers uh so I've been
with them quite some time and I started
my expertise in social media management
back in 2013 and basically self-taught
using the actual platform data and the
platform courses to enable myself I have
about 11 years total with sales
marketing customer service but with the
primary focus on digital marketing so as
these channels have evolved I have
evolved with them I have watched so many
changes happen across platforms and I'm
seeing a bunch of questions about all
these different things like chat GPT and
all of that I was here prior to any of
that
um any of those developments and
technology so uh I launched my agency
around that time uh it was a 2012 exact
when I launched my agency and all we did
was social media and now we do paid
marketing we do SEO we build websites we
do a number of different things but
primary focus is in paid media so that's
just a little blurb about me and I will
give it back to our hosts
uh thank you so much uh birthday uh
welcome again uh so we are going to just
talk about today's agenda uh so we'll be
talking about digital marketing careers
and what this program offers and uh how
this program will actually get your job
ready and also we'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps and the Q a
section so don't forget the Q a section
you can always go and add your questions
in the Q a box uh and we'll be taking
those questions throughout the webinar
uh so yeah
and let's start with uh careers in
digital marketing
uh but when you see digital marketing is
the backbone of racial economy how do
you think we have gotten to this point
uh where it has become the digital
ectomy boom
yeah that's a really great question so
one of the things that happened
especially during the pandemic and US
everyone having to work from home is
digital transformation as far as digital
transformation is concerned a lot of
people consumers actually change the way
that they did business just in general
day to day they ordered groceries online
they ordered clothes online they sent
school supplies online one of the
examples I like to use is I have a a
Target that's not far from where I live
but I still order stuff online when I
can just drive there so the mindset set
has shifted now digital marketing always
was super important because it allowed
businesses to be able to have presence
without having to have a super large
budget especially especially if they
were small business so essentially this
is why there's such a uh demand for
digital marketing because Technologies
are changing people are getting into
Full Throttle they're not going back to
the way that they did business anymore
they're actually propelling and Jet
setting to this new way of life and so
essentially businesses need to respond
they need to start to create
personalized experiences and this is
where we do that in careers in digital
marketing
uh that's that's a really good answer I
must say uh what do you think like uh we
have gotten to this point uh where uh
there are like new things right every
time you need to stay up to date with
the skills in business marketing you
cannot just learn one thing right so uh
what do you suggest for folks who
actually are starting off or in a
mid-career change as well uh yes
yes absolutely so learning learning
learning um as long as I've been in this
industry I have never stopped learning
about this field I am constantly taking
different certifications different
um courses different things going to the
actual platform like Tick Tock Google
Pinterest Instagram whatever you want uh
to kind of hang your hat on in terms of
platform I always go to their live
workshops because this is one of those
areas where it is constantly changing it
is technology that fuels this industry
so there's always going to be an
evolution if you are brand new or
thinking about making a change the best
way is to basically get into
certification programs such as this one
now this one has more of a comprehensive
look the second thing that you should do
is you need to figure out what part of
digital marketing that you would like to
really focus on I like to like in
digital marketing to almost like the
medical profession you have doctors who
are optometrists you have doctors who
are cardiologists you have all of these
different specializations right then you
have a generalist or a general practice
doctor that just kind of touches on
everything but even that person has to
Outsource out when he or she runs into
an issue of that they can't really solve
with their expertise so if you want to
become a generalist this particular
program actually helps to introduce you
to all of the disciplines and domains
that surround digital marketing but it
is also really good to become a
specialist because you want to have that
expertise or that subject matter
expertise that will center around a
specific discipline and you'll see if
you did a quick LinkedIn search you'll
see that a lot of that happens where
jobs or companies are looking for
someone that has a specific expertise in
one discipline in digital marketing and
this is what makes a a lot of the
opportunities much more ride arranged
and much more wider in terms of how you
enter into the field
well that's that's really amazing thank
you so much for answering that question
uh so meanwhile we are talking we
actually are getting uh questions for
the Q a part as well so we'll be taking
that in some time just to let you know
that folks have already started putting
their questions uh related to digital
marketing career so uh as I can see
there are many career options in digital
marketing uh but can you take us to what
career paths people can follow on
digital marketing
yeah absolutely so just like I mentioned
before you have all of these different
disciplines right you have your digital
marketing manager who basically oversees
a lot of the separate disciplines that
you see listed in this infographic so
you have email marketing manager content
marketing manager social media
strategist advertising PPC
e-commerce now we have creative
functions so now they're dealing with
the creatives and creating like videos
ugc content all of that SEO analysts
website marketing managers now the
digital marketing manager is centered at
the top of this slide here because they
typically manage all of these
disciplines and they need to understand
how they work interconnectedly in order
for them to get that this is usually a
senior level position and they've
probably worked one or two of these
disciplines so again you have to just
decide like what do you truly enjoy
doing do you enjoy creating content you
enjoy writing things do you enjoy enjoy
digital marketing or are sorry digital
advertising or paid marketing what do
you really enjoy and what companies are
out there looking for the things that
you're passionate about so that you can
Custom Tailor your career based off of
that
um that's that's amazing but there's
always this dilemma right like where do
you get started right yep would you guys
guide us like where where do you get
started you know like how to deal with
this dilemma
yep so I see here that some folks are
saying yeah you know I like content
writing I like you know graphic design I
like all of these different things
really and truly anything that you do in
life as a career it should feel like
that you're playing right it should feel
like that you go to work every day you
enjoy you go to sleep with all these
things or your mind like I do I have
this big huge brain and it's a thousand
ideas in there so I know that if I'm
going to do
um any type of creative work that's
going to get my goat right so taking
like even career assessments to see what
you enjoy before you decide to embark on
a specialist path will work now again
this program is designed to introduce
you to all of the facets of digital
marketing so that when you leave the
program you can decide hey you know what
when we did that section on email
marketing I really and truly enjoyed
email marketing I think I want to pursue
that further or golly I love social
media I love hanging out on Instagram
and and Tick Tock so I would love to
just simply manage that portion of the
business so I would get yourself
introduced get yourself educated on the
different disciplines and domains and
then decide what really sticks out what
really resonates with you and then once
you figure out what resonates with you
by maybe taking some free assessments or
just internally you know reflecting on
what resonates with you then embark on
that journey to specialize
I think that answers that definitely uh
so uh like do you really meet these many
skills in order to uh you know craft
this into my marketing role
no
you will drive yourself crazy trying to
master everything the the saying in the
west is is master of many ruler of none
right you it's good to have a workable
knowledge but you do not have to know
every single thing about digital
marketing before you get into the field
absolutely not and there are programs in
in uh internships or online you know
projects that you can actually jump on
that you can actually test out with
those skills are when I do teach classes
here I oftentimes refer my students to
acadium acadium is kind of like a
freelance dashboard they don't pay for
these projects but it allows you to
explore can I see this for myself long
term and then if you do a great job then
the company may knock on your door and
say you know what you did really well
with this we really enjoy what you did
with our company would you be interested
in coming to work with us full-time so
again you can decide how and where to
trajectory of your career goals and go
from there I started with implementation
and execution and I said to myself in
2011 guys well 2012 said to myself then
by the time digital marketing catches on
I will be teaching it and here we are
teaching it so and and we are happy to
have you here yeah so essentially you
just really have to find what you're
truly passionate about what you enjoy
doing and then take that trajectory but
you do not have to know everything that
is not a requirement
that's that's a very honest answer I
must say that uh you know folks actually
spent half of their life working in a uh
you know somewhere uh and later on
realizing that you know this is not
something they like you know it was
something else they figure it out pretty
late uh this way of figuring it out what
you have told me right through freelance
projects it's really amazing it saves
you a lot of a decade I would say you
know more than a decade of work you know
which will be doing which you might not
like so yep that's that's a really
helpful answer I must say yep absolutely
awesome uh maybe let's move on to a
quick poll as you can see on your screen
so uh we all have talked about the job
roles and we have talked about the
skills that you need so you all here
here because you need the digital
marketing certification uh you can see a
quick poll on your screen and uh the
options for those are like I could find
a program with a fully currently as a
curriculum so if that is what is
stopping you can choose that uh I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure to
become
you know expert so you can choose the
second option you can also choose the
third one I find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded videos uh the last one
is my work schedule won't allow me to
enough time for learning if that is
something you align with so you can see
quick goal uh on your screen if you'll
join from your laptop from your mobile
you can just click an option and submit
it so you'll get to know basically what
exactly it's stopping you uh from taking
the digital marketing certification and
we're going to help you out with your
questions you know queries which you
have uh and I can see we're getting
plenty questions in the Q a part as well
as well so keep that coming folks and
we'll be closing the poll in 10 seconds
so a few folks who have not voted uh
please do go and vote for the poll you
see on your screen what basically is
stopping you from taking this digital
marketing certification so uh I'll be
closing the poll in five seconds
five four three two
one oh you're getting a lot of answers
in the end okay let me just share the
result with your folks
as we can see uh what is stopping you
from taking the digital marketing
certification okay you can't find a
fully comprehensive program are
basically 35 percent of the folks I can
see half of the folks have said I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become a digital marketing
expert uh that is the biggest concern I
think they have and few of them have
said that I find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded videos and I can see a
few of them have said that my work
schedule wouldn't allow me to have
enough time for learning so that's great
thank you for your answers folks let's
move on to the next part
so uh we will talk about the Purdue
University program uh before I take you
through the Purdue University program uh
this program is a industry learning path
uh and in this program uh the you
actually get to work on comprehensive
curriculum which is industry aligned uh
and also the programs case studies and
hands-old project actually help you with
practical experience which actually
helps in boosting your job prospect and
we have an online live virtual classroom
with peers and instructor interaction so
why not it wanted to know uh the live
classroom virtual program which happens
uh how is it like is it interactive is
it boring like what kind of uh you know
classroom is this can you tell us a
little bit about the experience they
will be having in this classroom
yeah absolutely so one of the things
that I've always loved about the simply
learned program is definitely the
Hands-On projects the Hands-On things
that we do in class and when I am
instructing I always make a space for
the live classes to actually have that
Hands-On that group activity where we
can break out have these discussions and
really dive into the Hands-On part I
also come to the table with a lot of
experience so I bring in my examples of
things that I've actually run into the
tools that I actually use in my
day-to-day processes so that you all
will have an inside in this is something
that is not offered by like you know
your pre-recorded uh courses that some
of you guys mentioned you have a live
instructor that's answering your
questions in real time asking for
examples in real time and with all of
the projects that we have
um inside of each module you are able to
take those projects and present them to
potential employers and say Hey listen
I've been working on this certification
for six months these were the things
that we did inside of that class and
here's how I'm able to demonstrate my
expertise that I was able to acquire
also with having Harvard Business or
Purdue attached to a lot of that program
curriculum is going to bolster The
credibility that you have whenever you
are moving forward in pursuing your
career after getting your certification
so these certifications are now even
being looked for by employers like
they're just skipping decrees all
together I'm like hey do you have a meta
certification do you have a Google
analytics certification perfect please
come because in classes by the time you
if you think about it by the time you
complete your undergrad and it's nothing
against undergrad because I have an
undergrad degree and two masters by the
time you've completed it in undergrad
the technology has already changed
this program allows you to be able to
see what's happening in real time and
then set you on a path of this is how
you continuously refresh your knowledge
stay on top of the changes so that you
can be a successful professional
uh that explains it well uh also like
the program duration of this program is
six months and I can see that you just
need to give five to ten hours per week
is that really possible like how much
effort would you usually need to put in
in order to achieve that productivity
yeah so um the classes are typically in
the evenings on the weekends the only
problem uh that a lot of people face
with this is that you know is the cut or
the question that I get a lot is is the
class entertaining because this is a
night and weekend thing or how does this
work well we typically meet two times a
week for the live instruction and then
you have the autonomy of when you want
to complete your your uh projects that
you have that are due on that class uh
basis in the meantime when we do meet on
the weekends I am there as a guide to
walk you through what you need to be
looking for kind of looking over those
areas to tell you this is what you need
to improve this is what you need to take
out and so on and so forth but most of
the students that have successfully
completed this program did not find any
issues with the five to ten hour
commitment and in fact as you can see
I'm very animated I try to make them as
interesting as possible because I know
you guys are up until like 12 a.m in the
morning depending on where you are in
the world so these are some of those
areas that you know you really want to
think about when you're thinking about
any certification program that you want
to participate in your time commitment
to be in class is five to ten hours but
you may have a little bit of extra time
that you have to commit outside of the
times that we meet just to complete your
projects
awesome I think that makes sense thank
you so much uh for helping us with that
great uh so in this program what exactly
you'll be getting out of this program
you'll be getting a new postgraduate
certificate
University tag on your certificate while
applying for these jobs and you will
also get to work on Hands-On projects uh
Capstone project and master classes and
EMAs with Purdue and meta uh and also
you'll be a part of the podium
Association membership uh which
basically is a simpler alumni Community
uh where you get to network with a lot
of folks from around the world and also
uh have a close-knit circle of folks you
know who are studying with you so not
much different from an offline setting
but we try to make it possible you know
as much as possible for you folks to
interact with each other you know and
network with each other as possible
foreign
University Advantage uh has anyone heard
of Purdue before the session would love
to know on Jack yes or no
okay I if not let me take you through
the Purdue University Advantage okay I
can see folks responding yes some
obviouses some of know okay yes the best
Canadian someone has replied okay okay
okay fine fine maybe maybe let us take
you through that the advantage so Purdue
is a 150 year old University uh it has
been established by a land grant from
the state of Indiana and it is
consistently one of the top public
universities and has produced Nobel
Prize winners uh having a university
like Bernadette said is a very
prestigious accomplishment recognized
worldwide uh but would you like to tell
us a little bit about Purdue University
Advantage I think you have mentioned
that enough but a little bit about it
for folks to get an idea
yes so um when this program first
launched um I had the pleasure of
actually meeting the people who created
the curriculum
um for uh the simply learned partnership
and really and truly they wanted to
create this program with you in mind
thinking as someone that's breaking out
into the uh the the career field as a
beginner
um with having Purdue on your resume
like I said it is a prestigious
organization it's been around a very
long time and this is what you are
basically using as your own marketing
tool in order for you to be able to
Market your expertise you know a lot of
times when you start programs like this
accreditation is a concern sometimes who
you're aligned with is concern sometimes
and really and truly with having Purdue
there's other programs out there like
you know the the Yale kind of
certification plan this one has a little
bit more legs just because of the
Partnerships and the vast Alumni network
um there's a huge amount of alumni that
you can connect with especially in the
digital marketing space in this program
and they allow you access to their
Alumni network when you've completed the
program
oh that's that's great
yes you're located I think it is located
it's
ooh I forget which part of this uh which
state is located in I'll have to look
um but oh golly I know they did start
they did start the ground from the state
of Indiana that's where it is that's
right Indiana India yeah
also in addition to that we have this
meta Advantage as well uh which
basically has a better blueprint uh
exclusive ask me anything sessions by my
top and also master class is my media
experts and Industry recognize meta
blueprint certification exam prep and
voucher as well you'll be getting with
this program
and also uh job assist uh you know
assistance in India and usually we have
partnered with imjobs.com for India and
talenting for us so you through this you
get a resume building assistance and
career monitoring and interview prep
sessions we have a plus and also you get
to participate in career affairs
also we have the eligibility so uh you
don't have to be a FEMA marketing
background in order to take up to this
course but you need to have a bachelor's
degree in any discipline and at least
two years of work experience is required
uh so Bernadette uh coming from a no
marketing background do you see these
students succeeding after taking up this
course
um yeah again uh It's All About the
Passion that you have about the industry
when I came into this industry I was
actually in sales which sales and
marketing kind of go hand in hand right
but you actually have to sell the
product well marketing is actually the
the heartbeat of sales so it's kind of
like you have to have the right
packaging you have to have the right
value prompts and things like that but
let's say for instance you came from the
tourism industry or you came from any
industry the beautiful thing about
marketing is that it is found in every
aspect of business it doesn't matter
what background that you had before that
company had to have some kind of
marketing even for you to be in seat so
think of it as I may have worked in the
tourism industry or the restaurant
industry but just my presence my
attitude the knowledge that I had that
had to be marketed and so with that I
can still be able to have and launch a
successful career in marketing even if I
did not work in marketing specifically
and again this program is not so high
level that someone that has never taken
this course they're going to get
overwhelmed or inundated with knowledge
you can be at the very bottom you could
be at the very top and you're still
going to learn something new I've seen
this for a while uh doing this program
well that's that's amazing uh also like
we have talked about the folks who
actually don't come from a lot of
marketing background uh like what about
the folks who are actually coming from
the marketing background is there an
advantage for them
yes so um one of the things that they
can bring to the table is just what
their experience is and I've seen a lot
of people from different walks of life
that's like hey when I worked at this
program this is where I you know this is
where I can see that this particular
marketing principle works you know those
areas so I've seen people from
programmers to people who were just
project managers all of that really
contribute and help other students that
may not have had any information or any
like background knowledge to understand
like how things actually work and how it
can work in conjunction with digital
marketing so definitely one of those
areas where it's it's fluid in terms of
making that transition
that's great
uh I can see folks are asking
asking clear and q a box as well before
we start uh okay I think I think we have
been through this okay how this program
actually prepares you so uh the live
tour of leveling environment is
something binary it will be taking us
through I can see a lot of you folks you
were asking about this the learning
environment part uh so a few things you
can uh know about the learning
environment before we start is uh it
will help you in managing your
curriculum uh the live virtual classroom
will be there there will be test demos
which you can participate in a Capstone
project which we already have talked
about and overview of that uh progress
tracking you can unlock a certificate
based on the progress you make on this
course and also you will get support
tools as well so uh Benedict can you
take us through the live tour of the
learning environment
yes absolutely give me one second I was
trying to get you guys
[Music]
um I'm going to have to change the
review and then if you just give me
controls
I'll be able to share my stream I think
I can share my screen
okay one quick second I'm gonna stop my
video
meanwhile folks I can see you have asked
a lot of questions in the Q a box we'll
be taking that in some time
yeah I was trying to answer them in real
time
well it will take it maybe during the
learning session or the post that like
that like exactly so yeah so I'm gonna
log in here and then I will show you
guys
how this is
oh it's been a while since I've logged
in here but
it's okay
um
there are folks asking questions in the
chat as well like any programming
language was required to learn digital
marketing no no programming language
mostly Concepts and uh
Theory and then of course the Practical
execution of those but no programming
and things like that
I hope yep
yep no programming language required
love the questions about chat gbt every
time I do the new session sessions they
always ask about chat GPT so I'm going
to go ahead and share my screen now give
me like one second
so yo Russia I'm gonna uh because I'm
logged in now
all right folks let me know if you can
see my screen here in the chat
uh you can just reply yes or no uh yeah
I'll just reply yes or no in the chat I
just want to make sure everyone can see
okay uh like I can see that you know uh
like you have started screen sharing but
nothing is visible 100. okay like it's
coming as black maybe you just can you
try it again
okay okay it's coming for a few hooks
okay
yeah
okay it is
saying my screen share is pause but let
me try it once again give me one second
just one second
yeah it says screen sharing is possible
I don't know if you have to do something
on your end Russian yes yes just once
again
okay
okay just one second
sure
uh can you stop sharing once yep
absolutely
okay can you can you try now
yep
okay one second
I can see I can see the folks are
chatting over the message box
I can see Adrian has responded okay
thank you for the question you have
answered earlier okay very well
I think whenever I stopped sharing it
took me out so I'm gonna come back over
here
so I have made you the whole so you can
easily share just let me know if it's
not working hard yeah
okay perfect so let me click at it
again
meanwhile Folks by Bernardo sharing her
screen uh we have gotten a lot of
messages on the Q a box so please don't
miss out that if you're putting your
questions on the chat I might not be
able to take it because we might miss it
Miss out to have a lot of messages and I
can see your screen okay perfect so this
is what your LMS would look like or your
learning management system
um right now uh I don't have anything
active in here because usually they will
um basically go in and give me the
access to be able to manage like a
program but I'm just going to show you
the ones that I had in the past
so essentially once you do come in you
would go into your course and then it'll
show you like your progress like how far
you've gone along which classes that
you've already covered now as a
supplement to you all when you log into
your class you also have some
self-learning modules this is not the
bulk of your class the bulk of your
class comes with the live sessions but
your self-learning will be here and then
once you've completed the program you
would have your certificate and your
certificate would say unlocked and
you've completed or mastered all of the
portions of the course and then you
would come from here and then go into
your next class after it starts right so
after you've done that let me just
refresh real quick
you also turn in all of your assignments
all of your projects with the same area
in the same area also here you have
notes so you can take digital notes if
you'd like if you wanted to you know
just take notes while we were in class
this would actually show up by date
inside of the actual LMS so depending on
what class we were taking or what date
whatever notes that you took digitally
it would show up there then there's your
community so everyone in your class
would have a place for a forum that you
would log into to be able to communicate
with your classmates outside of class so
that way if you had questions or you
guys wanted to collaborate you would
have this thread and you all would be
able to collaborate on that thread now
typically I create a Google classroom
for my folks just so that I can kind of
create some camaraderie and things like
that but now that was before we had the
thread but now or the community but now
since we have the community they've
moved all of that so that it can all be
housed in one place then of course
there's the help tab so anytime you had
any tickets any questions any live class
uh
validations that you've needed to ask
this is where you would do that and the
support team typically gets back with
our Learners between 24 to 48 hours
depending on what the situation is now
back on that main page you also saw the
electives the electives right so I'm
going to go back to this
and you see how it has the electives you
have the option to take additional
electives that are based on the
specialization that you're interested in
in digital marketing now this is just an
example of the last course that I uh
that I was teaching at the time so I
haven't been enrolled in any of the
digital marketing but if the digital
marketing postgraduate program would
show up here it would say that and then
it would have all of the different
electives that are available to you to
take so you have a choice of taking
those there are labs in some of them and
there's self learning content and some
of them actually have live classes once
you've completed all of the course
requirements your certificate your
program certificate would show up here
it is branded to Purdue so it will say
Purdue that you've completed the program
and you'll be able to have that as proof
that you were involved with the cohort
that was aligned with Purdue now while
you're going through the program all of
the program uh modules at the end of
those programs those certificate will
say simply learned you don't get the
Purdue certificate until you've
completed all of the courses right so
here's your profile this is all of your
exam your invoices your support requests
any subscriptions that you have any
certificates that you're receiving here
and then any resources that you would
like to access and that focuses just how
our learning management system works
fairly straightforward and simple to use
and again this is also where we would
meet so once you get into the course
this is where you would meet with us in
order for us to be able to have our live
sessions ask questions and then walk
through some of those Hands-On exercises
and labs
and I'll stop sharing here and get it
back to you Russia
oh yeah sure oh so I've made a horse can
you okay
let me just share my screen back
by the way that was a really great tool
of the live environment
no problem
so uh we just talked about the live
environment
uh of this course and we are taking
basically a live sample session uh where
we can see the project description and
all the skills to be learned uh let's
talk more about the uh steps which
basically helps us build uh you know
these skills step by step so whether can
you take us through these steps which
actually helps in building your original
marketing skills through this program
yeah absolutely so the it starts off
with the fundamentals of digital
marketing and SEO now a lot of our
students like to talk about SEO because
this is one of those areas where this is
a lot of organic traction so we start
off with that and why it's important to
the marketing mix into the digital
marketing profession then we go into PPC
where you have some Hands-On Labs
projects things like that to walk
through in that environment web
analytics super important for both paid
media and organic media it tells you and
analyzes the customer Journey the
traffic all of these different areas
then you go into social media marketing
where there's a project that you are
going to do in each class there is a
project so all of these projects
basically build off of another which
leads us to the digital marketing
Capstone project so digital marketing
Capstone project is a combination of all
of these disciplines and domains that
are that you see here and once you have
completed those then you have that now
if you look here at those electives
that's where those electives were that I
were telling you guys about you have
your digital marketing meta master class
which will help you with your meta
certification should you need to uh
pursue that and just FYI having a better
certification very valuable to your
career so definitely if you
um so so happen to sign up for the
course go ahead and pursue that meta uh
certification you get the voucher for it
anyway then of course you have the
Purdue digital marketing Master Class
brand management this is huge in the
digital marketing world and I would
invite you guys to just go on to
LinkedIn and just type in your specific
area wherever you are or if you're
thinking of doing something traveling
abroad or doing something like that look
at how many jobs are in the brand field
the email marketing field the content
marketing field look at how many jobs
generate for those particular
disciplines and see whether or not ahead
of time if you'd like to take this as an
elective and then of course mobile
marketing which is more of a Geo
targeting sort of thing there's some
outside technology that a lot of times
is employed to make sure that mobile
users are getting marketed to regardless
of where they are and that's pretty much
how the program actually gets you to
develop those skills it focuses the
zeros in on the niches gives you the
labs and the Hands-On projects and then
after that you put it all together so
that you can execute what you're doing
we're not just sitting down reading
slides we are giving you full live
examples of what you should be doing
what you should be focused on and how to
execute that in your career
but that's amazing and also about
elective path uh so these electives are
a part of this program they are optional
but uh but you don't have to pay
anything extra for that it comes in the
this program fee itself
also uh as we can see that there are
many tools and platforms that you'll get
to learn in this program uh but uh but
we know that these are not only the
tools which you're seeing on the screen
there are many more tools you know apart
from this uh but it can you take us
through mainly like few tools which they
will be learning in this program
yeah absolutely so the Keyword Planner
and Google ads
um that happens whenever we get into uh
PPC and I really enjoyed this section of
the course because
um there's been a lot of changes with
Google ads so we have like G4 now
um there is now this is no longer
Twitter it's X so then you learn X ads
you learn some HootSuite background
things Facebook ads Facebook ads and and
how that uh manages in the marketing mix
we go on a little bit of kind of a
scavenger hunt to understand Google
analytics and where to find and
interpret the data there S E ranking is
a tool that helps us to understand like
where certain searches are if we're
going to be pursuing SEO sem Rush same
thing we learned I'd use some sort of I
use some of their materials to be able
to display or kind of convey some of the
main Concepts and then of course YouTube
advertising now the cool thing about all
of these interfaces is is you pretty
much learn like their processes what
their platforms have to offer and so on
and so forth
well that's amazing thank you so much
for the introduction of the tools and
platforms and uh as we're talking about
the tools uh they get to work on real
business implication projects as well uh
so how does having these projects on
your CD help with getting uh you know
the job of your dreams and click
marketing
yeah some companies are now in again
this is why I employ you guys to go and
look onto some of those job descriptions
right those job descriptions are written
by recruiters a lot of the time
sometimes they are written by the hiring
manager when you go to the description
of what skills that they would like for
you to have
even if you are brand new having
something that you have worked on and
your observation and what you were able
to execute can kind of bypass some of
those years of experience now if you've
never been in this industry then you're
going to be looking at junior or
mid-level positions but if you're
wanting a senior level then even having
some of these projects or having some of
these will help you to be able to convey
that even though I may not have five to
seven years of experience I I have put
my hands on projects that have helped me
to really interpret the aspects of
digital marketing that impact business
and so Air France is one of the
companies that we take a look at Trip
Advisor according Yahoo and there's a
specific kind of a scenario that you
would put your hands on and then figure
out a creative way to
um deploy whatever that project
description is for you to deploy now
while you're doing that we also kind of
open it up for or other companies to
have the discussion inside of class so
that you can look at other examples
before you do before you deploy your
actual assigned projects so we get an
opportunity to see people from different
backgrounds talk about those projects or
talk about the experiences that we had
and imply our knowledge to it definitely
helps on a CV to be able to present your
projects that you have done your
expertise that you have Acquired and a
real live portfolio version of what you
were able to do so that they can see if
they handed you this role right now
today this is exactly how you would
execute it
also the Capstone projects right we have
talked about the Capstone projects a lot
even in the initial starting of the
session uh so how does having a Capstone
project completely change your portfolio
in digital marketing
yeah absolutely the Capstone project is
encompasses several different
disciplines several different domains so
when you're doing your search on
LinkedIn and you go in and you look at
all of these different tools and things
that they would like for you to have uh
experience in this Capstone project is
going to cover email marketing PPC
social media all these different areas
that you can say I completed a project
and I covered all of these areas of
digital marketing this was my findings
this is how I would execute it today it
also serves as a guide that if you
wanted to stand out amongst everybody
else right even if you wanted to stand
out amongst everyone else in the crowd
you could actually recreate that
Capstone project for that business
because you already have a framework you
already have a blueprint so when you go
into that interview you can say Hey
listen in the certification that I took
with Purdue I actually created just kind
of a framework of if I were chosen for
this role today this is how I would
execute my marketing plan so having that
blueprint to be able to translate
because as you know everybody's trying
to look for it particularly look for
remote positions digital marketing
things like that so this will help you
with your portfolio to say this is a
strategy or this is a plan that I would
use right now today in your business to
help you to grow and meet your goals and
so I think that that's really valuable
even if no nothing else which is why I
spend a lot of time on tax Zone when I
do these sessions if nothing else will
be helpful having that Capstone as your
blueprint to be able to recreate and
present to companies that you're
interested in working for definitely is
a value-add
that's great and and as we can see that
we have different different Capstone
projects you know which they can use to
Showcase their future employer uh
there's an online Apparel Store one uh
all in for Marketplace all in Gadget
Show retail shop and mobile app design
platform so uh all of these projects are
worked on individually or is it just
like a part of the captain project like
covered
yeah um so essentially they don't cover
all of them they have an opportunity to
choose which one that they do so it's
not going to be each and every one of
them they'll be able to choose which one
which aspects and then go from there
um sometimes now there may have been
changes uh and we can always dive into
that when you start but each class that
you take from the intro class all the
way down to the Capstone everything that
we're doing is building up to the
Capstone so whatever changes that have
gone on in the program you'll be
communicating that which each class that
you take you also have the the ability
to be able to just really focus on the
area that you really want to work it
work in that's why they have these
options here
awesome
uh also we have like global leaders as
program of advisors uh black gingerly
who actually is a clinical assistant and
professor of management in Berlin
University Brad Gates uh who actually is
a founder of certified knowledge and
author at Matt Bailey who is an expert
internal marketer and president of site
logic and also as an author so uh these
global leaders actually make sure that
simply learn is delivering as per
standards to the students here and we
are really proud to be a part of that
uh so we are going to be talking about
past Learners and their success uh so in
in this particular program we actually
get Learners profiles by industry and
they come from different different uh
companies like Amazon Microsoft uh
Vodafone LinkedIn uh dell Etc and also
they come from a diverse set of
Industries which makes it more
interesting from it uh from Consulting
from the FSI and others uh this makes it
a very interesting combination uh to be
a part of such a diverse alumni group
and also uh we have like few success
stories here as well uh who actually
tell you a little bit about the program
uh we can see Korean here who actually
uh has taken this additional marketing
course and it has been already like
three years with simply learn and uh the
he says that the plan this particular
course and the platform are top of the
industry standard and we can see uh
about here as well who actually is a
digital marketing manager in uh one of
the Jamaica's leading advertising agency
and this particular certification
allowed him uh to uh become a game
changer and start his own company and
scale up his business and just like that
we have uh here with us as well uh who
is an instructor was uh through uh while
uh explaining that it's a marketing in
depth who says that and also uh it was
very exciting for uh her to be you know
uh interactive with the uh basically
instructor and also the peers in the
class and basically she could take up
this class anywhere she wants
I would love to know that are you
interested in enrolling in this PG
program
while they're doing that Russia there
was a question and I really love this
question so I hope that you're still uh
I hope that this person is still on
um this uh person put in because there's
a lot of material available that's free
on the net what are you offering in it
and is it practical practical per the
needs of the market we'll be able to run
marketing on the net by digital
marketing on completion please share
some details this question is very
layered first of all you are absolutely
correct there are
um a lot of materials and a lot of
things free on the internet but it does
not have the credibility that the Purdue
University uh program has that's very
important when you're trying to get out
and find people that are willing to
exchange dollars for your time having a
credible source of information
um I always liking it too and you guys
may chuckle you know it's a difference
between YouTube University and Purdue
University there's a lot of people that
got their education from YouTube
University but when you try to go to
sell that marketable skill you can't
sell it because it doesn't have the
Branded stamp of credibility on it the
next part of your question is absolutely
it is very practical this program now
the last part of your question about
will we be able to run digital marketing
by the time the program ends that is
contingent upon how well you take in the
information we can't guarantee that
you'll just be an expert by the end of
the course but we can guarantee that the
amount of knowledge and the quality of
knowledge that you receive will
definitely get you on a stronger path
than most people that are trying to
figure it out on their own take it from
somebody who knows I've had to figure
all of this out on my own I had to come
in and find because there were no
programs that were available to me when
I started in digital marketing in fact
you only had you know whoever Guru
decided that they were going to be a
guru in the search certain area so I
just want to employ you guys that when
you take things seriously and you take
programs seriously there are a lot of my
students that have gone on to work for a
lot of really great companies with the
knowledge that they got out of this
program but the knowledge does not stop
when the program ends you still need to
learn hey what changes on The Tick Tock
platform that are causing more business
to be able to uh be generated from there
what's happening on Facebook now what's
going on with you know creatives what ad
formats are they offering what's
happening on the Google side they just
sunset at an entire platform and
introduced what they call G4 so you have
to understand that how is g chat gbt
playing a role in all of this how is it
starting to implicate or or become a
negative impact because a lot of people
are fascinated with chat gbt but not
everyone knows that it is starting to
have a negative impact on platforms if
it's just copied right out of the
technology so keep all of this in mind
whenever you're deciding a program we
may or may not be a fit for you but at
the end of the day I want you guys to
have a passion about this industry if
you're going to enter it don't do it
just because of the money do it because
you're really passionate about it
I can see our folks are already
responding on chat here uh if they're
interested in the program let's move on
to the enrollment steps uh so for the
enrollment you uh need to follow three
simple steps you need to submit an
application and uh application review
and uh you will have to then get the
admission so your application will be
going in review in the second step and
based on that you'll be getting the
admission uh so the next cohort of this
class starts at September 7th uh and uh
ends at uh September 30. and the price
is USD 3000 and uh in India it is one
lakh one triple line so we will be
taking the Q a part of the questions now
I I think I can see that uh we have
answered few of the questions from the Q
a but folks feel free to uh put down
your questions on the Q a box here we'll
be taking the Q a questions here now
so just to start with uh like uh I can
see uh one of the folks have asked like
which is better for beginners uh being a
specialist or a generalist digital
marketer
what do you think
yeah that is that's kind of a nuanced
question because maybe being a
generalist is overwhelming for one
person and interesting for another so I
would say that it just depends on you
but as an as a beginner you can do
either now let me just add a little bit
of a caveat in there
um most companies would want you to have
experience to be a full-on digital
marketer or a generalist so our digital
marketing manager or general so just
keep that in mind as you're going
through your Pursuits but the best way
for you to determine where you want to
be is to essentially do that LinkedIn
search look for someone that has you
know maybe zero to five years of
experience and just check out to see
okay these are skills that I know that I
can acquire these are skills that I
might have to learn on the job and so on
and so forth but either or is just fine
awesome
uh I think I can see few of the
enrollment
so basically uh if you're a few of the
folks are actually asking about the
enrollment part they want to actually
put down yes to actually get more
information about this program so I am
launching
this question uh this poll you will see
on your screen right now so would you
like to enroll in the program you can
select yes if you are interested in
rolling and I want to know more about
the program and meanwhile you're doing
that we'll be taking the Q a questions
uh post this uh more questions on uh q a
box which you are getting
yeah
I can see a lot of responses coming in
a few other folks who have not voted yet
you can just choose one of the options
like would you like to enroll in this
posterior program of judicial marketing
with Purdue University if your answer is
yes you can select yes you can see the
question on your screen if you're joined
from your laptop or your mobile you can
see your Polo on your screen and you can
just choose an option yes if you like to
enroll in the program no if you don't
want to currently I will explore more
about that again just submit that pool
so I'll be closing the spoon in 10
seconds
meanwhile other few folks who have not
voted uh please do vote on your screen
if you are interested in enrolling in
this program uh pgp uh in digital
marketing by Purdue University you can
see the poll on your screen yes or no
and if you your answer is yes you can
just click it on the screen uh either
you have joined from a laptop or mobile
and uh we will be sharing the results in
five seconds I'll give you five more
seconds
for the poll for a few other folks who
have not voted yet so five four three
two one I'm ending the poll down thank
you so much folks for voting
let me share the results so 73 percent
of the folks are interested in enrolling
the program and a few of them are still
thinking about it I'm gonna say
uh fine let's get back to the Q a part
of the session
so we were taking questions so I can say
a question in the Q a uh from admin okay
we will we have a mentor to guide us
even after the course is completed will
there be updates once the course is over
as the trend change changes sooner than
we learn so yeah wanna read what do you
think
absolutely I think that'd be great
awesome uh also I can see that uh one
person has asked like are there
certification SEO social media
advertising content creation uh as a
part of the program or do we find other
certifications of this program so
apparently this part of the program uh
covers digital marketing
um uh and but you can find I think few
parts of it right about a date like
maybe like SEO or social media
advertising in this program right
yeah so when you take the electives
those are all certificate of completions
that you receive
um so uh but in terms of it being very
extensive companies really uh want to
show that you can exercise that data I
mean anyone can get a certification but
you need to be able to exercise that
theory and exercise that content so
essentially
um you'll get a certificate of
completion uh that you can use but I
think really and truly having a
portfolio that shows that you were able
to bring a company or bring something
from point A to point B is going to be
much more valuable for you
that makes sense and uh like I can see
like when jarubi has asked like what
should you focus on if you want to put
up a digital marketing agency while
taking up this course
um I think I answered well I was trying
to answer it I might not have gotten to
it a generalist definitely because
you're going to be managing a lot of
people that are going to be
um basically executing a lot of those
disciplines
I hope that answers your question
okay I think one person has asked like
is this program six months or eight
months this program is of six months and
you can complete it by just investing
five to ten hours a week
and uh let's take other more questions
okay I can see like folks are firing up
on the Q a section here
yeah uh okay kirtana has asked like like
I don't have any experience in work can
I join the digital marketing course
yeah absolutely
yes I hope that answers your question
and uh some someone has asked like uh
what are we going to learn from this
course I think we have gotten through
and explained this uh you know this
discussion about it uh but uh if you
want to go through it again we'll be
sharing a recording link post webinar as
well in case you want to go through it
again and sound better and obviously uh
like if you have selected yes to enroll
uh someone from Simply learns a learning
consultant team will be getting in touch
with you to get get you uh in you know
in touch with more details about the
course
okay I can see one question from Kabhi
uh can someone with a full-time job also
manage the demands of the job workers
someone with a full-time job answer the
domains of what I'm sorry
of job workers basically I think he's
trying to ask that uh with a full-time
job can I actually you know complete
this course with the working job as
yeah absolutely most of our students are
full-time workers so they uh again if
you are in certain parts of the country
the classes in the evenings if you work
in the evenings
um if if not uh then if you're in the
states in certain parts of the world
sometimes it's in the mornings but and
it's usually on the weekends when most
uh professionals working professionals
are off but yeah you could definitely
complete it while you have a full-time
job it's just whenever we have the
availability of when the course is set
to run
um just give us a call and I mean our
when you enroll you can kind of just see
like what times they are so that you can
uh arrange your schedule according
awesome uh thank you so much for the
answer I think uh let's just take one
last hole uh would you like how to how
soon do you would like to enroll in this
program
you can see a poll on your screen uh
would you like to enroll immediately or
for the folks who have answered yes I
would recommend that highly to choose
that option and if you are planning to
enroll in this program within three
months you can choose the second one
within six months the third one okay
you're all still thinking about it
you're like more than six months from
now would be okay so the fourth one is
something that would work out for you
and for folks while you're voting you
can see the question on your screen you
will see a poll with four options where
basically how soon do you plan to enroll
in the digital marketing program uh with
Peru University uh folks who have chosen
yes I would highly recommend to choose
immediately to get to know uh the
upcoming cohort which you can join in
and folks who are planning to join
within three months can choose the third
option I can see folks have started
already started voting it so uh I would
suggest like few other folks who are
still voting like thinking about when do
you exactly want to enroll uh I would
suggest to uh choose an approximate
option which you think is okay
will be getting in touch with you to
take you uh through a thorough uh
description of the program as well you
know before you take it so don't worry
about that
so I'll be giving 15 seconds more for
the poll and uh I can see uh most of the
questions we have answered from the Q a
section
and while folks are voting and I'll be
closing the poll in uh 10 seconds
meanwhile I can see it on chat okay uh I
think tapan wants a video recording uh
so yeah you will be getting a video
recording post webinar over email which
you can view uh in case you know you
want to go through the session again
that would be great uh for and uh I can
see folks on the Q a section are still
uh asking questions as well so uh fine I
will be attending the poll now let me
just share the results
I can see that uh 90 19 of the folks
wants to join immediately and uh 31
percent folks are looking within three
months and 90 of the folks uh want to
join within six months and few of them
actually want to join from more than six
months from now
so uh thank you so much folks thank you
Bernadette for joining us and you know
taking us through a really good tour of
uh you know digital marketing program
with Purdue University uh I must say
that was pretty energetic I'm pretty
sure your classrooms must be much more
energetic than this one and we're just
seeing a trailer of it
yeah most of the time because I really
when I first started here of a lot of my
students were kind of having to go
overnight they were like I think the
class ended at like one or something
like that and golly if I were boring
then you'd go to sleep
so I try to be as energetic as possible
thank you thank you so much uh again
folks who have any other questions for
us you can always reach out to us at ask
us at simplyon.net uh so I'll be ending
the session today and thank you for
being a lovely audience thank you for
being a very lovely and interactive
audience I must say thank you so much
have a good night everyone have a good
morning a good afternoon wherever you're
joining us from thank you so much